las sirenas se han vuelto a disparar en
el este de ucrania también las hemos
oído nosotras aquí en micro donde nos
encontramos la localidad de poltava a
poca distancia de aquí ha sido alcanzada
por un nuevo ataque según informaciones
del gobierno ucraniano se trataría de al
menos cinco misiles que habrían
impactado contra infraestructura de esta
ciudad que además también está ubicada a
poca distancia de jarc y otra ciudad
martirizada por los enfrentamientos que
han continuado a producirse durante el
día de hoy también ha habido ataques en
nikoláyev y en la ciudad de gerson
ocupada por las fuerzas rusas hace
varias semanas de esta forma este país
ha vivido la pascua ortodoxa una fiesta
religiosa muy importante tanto para los
ucranianos como para los rusos que sin
embargo la población de este país ha
vivido con inquietud y desazón